came to ukraine six months ago fleeing
the taliban with his family he never
dreamed he'd still be here now i'm
really shocked the worst thing is you
know i have a pregnant woman i'm just
surprised i'm just shocked about this
issue that what will i do with this
woman if the war is started stuck in a
foreign country with an expectant wife
no language skills no money and no
support
hakmal and his 11 family members landed
in kiev as a transit stop they hoped on
their way to canada the former canadian
forces interpreter was rescued from
kabul after the taliban took over his
connection to canada put his life at
risk and his families
we met the huck malls in october when
their temporary visas expired they'd
spent nearly every hour of every day in
their hotel which is paid for by the
globe and mail
it helped him and another afghan
interpreter who worked for the paper to
safety
the kids are bigger now and they're
happy to see new faces
and play
their dad however says he isn't giving
them the life they deserve
this was not his plan for them if by
chance the prime minister or the
immigration minister or the defense
minister sees this
what do you want to say to them i will
tell them i'm a human like you too you
put me in there you don't care about me
and the time you needed me you used me
anger born out of pain and fear his
calls go on returned his questions
unanswered like thousands of others he
says he's told only his application is
being processed we reached out to
multiple government departments for
comment ircc sent a statement saying it
is doing the utmost to process cases
there is nothing else for me nothing no
hope is left for me his family back in
afghanistan asks about the war in
ukraine he lies and says there are no
worries no risks
but privately he fears what could happen
next
crystal gamansen global news
keeve